racism is awful and it should be stamped
out wherever it rears its ugly head but
I think we can all agree that the demand
for racism has started to exceed Supply
there's now a whole sede of celebrities
complaining about racism when it didn't
even happen the best example of this was
Jesse Smet remember him a Pampered
Hollywood actor who wanted to feel the
raw hatred of racism so much that he
organized his own lynching he employed
two men Aben bowler endro and olabinjo
endro to attack him now I've been all
over this big beautiful world of ours
and I have never met a white supremacist
called abin Bola or alabin
sry it's a funny line or abingo Jesse
hired two Nigerian Lads to beat him up
poor bleach on him and put a noose
around his neck now Jesse is gay so
maybe if he went to certain parts of
Africa that might very well be the
outcome but not in Chicago Chicago is so
gay that it's even got one of the most
popular musicals in history named after
it an Elton John in the middle of a
12-man gang bang is straighter than a
musical but at least Jesse believes in
diversity and hired Nigerians for the
role of white supremacists because if
the 21st century has taught us anything
it's that you can identify as anything
you want men can identify as women women
can identify as men and two massive
Nigerian Lads can identify as members of
the KKK racism doesn't just mean being
hateful and discriminatory to minorities
anymore racism can also just mean being
white in the same room as someone who
isn't white BBC radio presenter nahal
araki has said an overwhelmingly white
working environment is affecting his
mental health I know how he feels last
week I went into a Caribbean restaurant
and noticed I was the only white person
there as a result of my horrendous
experience I had a breakdown and was
carted off to the Looney Bin it was very
upsetting being carried out of raster
Jimm's Chicken Shack wearing a straight
jacket while screaming the words black
black black my eyes it was awful I'll
never be the same again when I was
released back into the community I got
my lawyer to send the restaurant a
strongly worded email explaining that
when I have my goat curry with rice and
peas I need to have a white person to
look at as it calms me down if there's
no white people in a place I start to
feel a bit anxious the way a dog does if
it's owner leaves it outside a
supermarket for too long it reminded me
of that awful time I went on a holiday
to Namibia when my plane landed I
immediately had a breakdown and had to
be taken home by air ambulance I was
signed off work for the rest of the year
and had an exclusion order implemented
so that black people couldn't come
within a 10 m radius of me it's the only
way to stop racism obviously I'm joking
but Nal sadly wasn't the insane thing
about his complaint is that there is an
over representation of ethnic minorities
in the BBC 42% of the BBC's employees
are from an ethnic minority background
and only 18% of the UK population are
ethnic minorities the BBC is now so
diverse that all straight white men are
identifying as neurodivergent just to
get a foot in the door although if Nal
is surrounded by autistic men I can
understand why he might feel
uncomfortable it's never easy sharing a
space with men who see the world in the
same way as a Terminator there's nothing
millionaire celebrities love more than
pretending that they're a victim the
queen of this or should I say Duchess is
Megan marle Megan represents the
American dream she came from a normal
background became a Hollywood actress
and then married a prince that is the
journey most little girls and gay men
dream about yet Megan Sees victimhood at
every turn apparently speculating on the
color of her unborn baby is racism it's
not racism there is no one on this
planet who isn't fascinated by what The
Offspring of a mixed race woman and a
ginger would look like who wouldn't want
to see what an afro Tangerine looks like
my bet is that even though the kid might
have curly hair and be a quarter black
it won't be able to get a tan 2 minutes
in the Sun and it'd come back looking
like a really angry pimple James ht's
Ginger jeans are very strong Megan and
Harry have monetized this egregious
remark into podcast and Netflix series
making their persecution seem as
horrific and vile as aparte South Africa
there were even rumors that little
Archie would have to use a different
water fountain at Buckingham Palace
Archie is going to be just fine he's
Rich descendant of royalty and he's
white of course he's white he's called
Archie for heaven's sakes it doesn't get
much whiter than that it's not like they
called him dcoin or although that would
have been hilarious but not as funny as
if they' called him Muhammad now that
really would have given Charles an
aneurism imagine hearing the words arise
King Dean Muhammad I it'll be worth it
just to see The Daily Mail headlines the
most egregious example of the race card
being played is when Bill Cosby's legal
team overturned the numerous convictions
against him and declared it justice for
Black America now Black America has
faced many horrific historical
injustices but I don't think Bill Cosby
being convicted of horrendous sexual
offenses is one of them I can't imagine
that many black people saw Bill Cosby's
trial and went we lost a good man there
more people would trust their teenage
daughter with OJ Simpson than Bill Cosby
although Cosby's so old now that if he
did try and put ripol in your drink he'd
forget which one it was and end up date
raping himself that's a problem with
being a prolific sex offender it's a
young man's game the other awful thing
about the sex offender community is that
women are disgustingly underrepresented
until we have females offending at the
same rate as males then we'll be
continuing to live in a patriarchy as we
all know there is no difference between
men and women so why aren't there more
female sex offenders and by the way the
odd PE teacher shagging their
16-year-old pupil ain't going to cut it
up your game ladies we all know that
racism still exists but thankfully it's
dying a slow and painful death the
horrible events of the previous C will
hopefully be a thing of the past and if
racism wasn't dying out then would a gay
black man really need to pay a couple of
crap actors to organize a lynching but
then if amberin wife of Henry VII can be
played by a black actress then why can't
abin Bola and olabinjo be white
supremacist and if reality doesn't
matter then maybe Megan is right to be
offended by an innocuous inquiry into
the color of her unborn child and maybe
convicting one of the most notorious
celebrity rapists is an act of racism to
paraphrase a great man it's progress Jim
just not as we know it before you go
give me a minute to tell you about our
partners give send go do you remember
the Canadian trucker protest in 2022
where thousands of Canadians came out to
protest covid restrictions and vaccine
mandates now these protests lasted for
weeks and the people out on the streets
needed funds as any Grassroots protest
would so people set up online
crowdfunding campaigns reach rais
millions of dollars incredible but those
campaigns were closed down and the money
didn't get to the protesters because the
Canadian authorities started to
criticize the crowdfunding platforms
ramping up pressure on them to close the
campaigns the biggest crowdfunding
platform the one we've all heard of
completely capitulated to the demands
now this is where our partners give send
go come in they stepped in when the
other platforms backed off and raised
millions of dollars for the truckers
when they were criticized and dragged
through the Canadian courts Gib and go
came out and said quote they respect
diverse views and believe hope and
freedom are values worth fighting for
this is why we're proud to partner with
them so if you need to crowd fund for
whatever means the most to you then
don't go to the big Tech platforms we
recommend you do it on giv send go
starting a campaign on giv send go is
easy and intuitive go to give send
go.com today that's giv send go.com to
start raising money for whatever's
important to you if you like this
monologue and I know you did check out
another one I did called porn stars for
Palestine